germany's foreign minister joined his EU
colleagues in rejecting any russian
annexation of Crimea he said the idea of
redrawing Europe's borders was
unacceptable but he believes the threat
isn't over the emission gets for za
Gaddafi Loftin we must now ensure that
the already tense situation does not
turn into further escalation by the
escalade soon and in which in the end
carries the risk of a military
confrontation in the middie between
russian forces and ukrainian forces
within ukraine is but cannot do klinikum
EU foreign ministers say that is good
reason to broaden sanctions eight top
politicians in Crimea and 13 political
and military figures in Russia now phase
travel bans and asset freezes it's part
of a three-phase sanction plan against
Moscow the e use first step was to
impose stricter visa requirements for
Russia now it's in phase 2 travel bans
and asset freezes against individuals
the EU has also reserved the right to
impose economic sanctions against Russia
the blocks there's only Russia can
prevent the last step by allowing OSCE
observers into Crimea and ending what
the West ceases coercive policies
towards Ukraine and we call on the
Russian leadership not to take steps to
annex Crimea and instead to take steps
to de-escalate this crisis Russia should
withdraw its forces and begin direct
discussions for the government of
Ukraine if Russia refuses to relent EU
heads of state and government could
prepare to impose economic sanctions on
Russia at their crisis summit later this
week